the Joe Rogan experience buh-buh-buh-buh
too much do you still enjoy the shows
though no you know fans may or may not
watch or listen to this right you're
they're performing yeah whenever
whenever I does whenever I've done shows
with him at the moment cuz you know I'll
hang out cuz after every show he'll try
to sell merch and take pictures but uh
as soon as he gets in the greenroom he's
like hey gee do you see how hard I work
you see this you see all this I'm doing
right you don't know nothin about this
hard work like okay you know five six
weeks in a row that's what I hate I'm on
I'm on my second of five weeks it's a
second second week now so I gotta go
next weekend I go to Hartford
Connecticut Hartford Springfield that's
why you you actually flying to that then
I go to Memphis so where you said you
hate it but what why don't you just stop
paper
the only time the only time I've ever
seen him do anything outside cuz he's
old school so it's one of those things
where he's so used to like you know he's
so you see he got his agents and
managers and he's so used to someone
giving him work so that's one of things
where I'm you know on the road you're
given the spot to get clubs and I was
like what do you like doing cuz you
asked that earlier and like the one
thing that we've made between like him
doing comedy and now is we created a
YouTube channel for him where he does
like a cooking show right so he has he
has his own YouTube channel cuz I do
YouTube and all this stuff I do like
gaming videos and a bunch of other
random stuff sketches and vlogs but he
was like whoa he's like I guess I got a
little time off we can do something
brand he's like maybe we can do this
cooking idea guy and I said sure let's
do it we create the channel we make it
and it's called cooking for poor people
poor people because when you're hungry
everything tastes good yes and his
channel is Dijon crap a bunch of crap
but he can check it feed it rice
chicken chicken with the chicken feet
pig feet oxtail what does chicken feet
like tough asian people either he tried
to feed it to our dog and our dog ran
away from him so that's like a cliff
don't know what else it was yeah and
then I recommend wine I have wine tall
glass of mad dog 20/20 with the chicken
with chicken feet and Thunderbird
Thunderbird one everyone yeah Cisco well
mad dog 20/20 so Mexican salad yeah
hanging out in the front with the bottle
did bring it down here and hide it
behind the crate and they bring it up in
your dead son yeah yeah you go buy some
more in it here we go yeah I helped them
produce and create homework on this
thing you know it gets good you didn't
pick favorite in shelli's do my [ __ ]
away I can't believe she'd do the whole
pig feet away oh I like the kitchen
- yeah that's old school whose kitchen
is that it says house we have we bought
the house next to us all right so I got
the house next to me and I told the
whole Finch now guess house kitchen and
we got oh that's a perfect kitchen full
show on cooking yeah it's tight and
old-school
it reminds you of like growing up yeah
and it works well you know we we predict
well I think we may maybe 12 15 of these
things but people watch them it's just
one of the things he works on the road
side whenever
free time comes around we used to sit
back and knock him out and try to shoot
him and I would edit them and whatnot
but now I'm busy so he has an editor so
but you know I try to help him market it
when it's like finished I'm like all
right posted on the social platforms get
it out there when that